finishing our button check now going
into character selection so there's one
thing I want to mention I don't know if
it's actually going to come up at any
point in time but there's the
possibility of him playing key llyich
because he did so versus you Toto's as
well at Southeast Asia maybe all right
well you know what he's a survey though
again I don't think it'll come up but it
says but if it's something that I have
to mention here we go
taking a breather to the moment
graduating all right here we go
so this stage actually some cool
properties about it the side walls do
shift into corner walls in between each
round all right here we go heading into
Game one and losers side [ __ ] pinnacle
very own shin-chan versus B DG's blue
god let's get it going
it's all I mean you know despite the
fact that strengths and hates his
character he's probably got some of the
most practice versus his character in
general and if anybody's gonna do it it
could very well be him does he get the
play hold up oh what a step right there
catching blue god pressing just one too
many buttons on that able to catch him
and taking the round on that
I mean I like it though it giving him
giving him an overwhelming like set of
options that should tend to go through
because now he's got to think about the
next time Zhen Shan is up close to this
place
don't worry food I got our turn Damon
just call back if you like that's that's
that's one more common the higher level
you and you're gonna caliber because no
player wants to play in such a way that
somebody's gonna get a fake hit the you
just said you're just forced to kind of
poke and get a little amateur in there
the back escape though you know I mean
we got his okay this is his first chance
to be able to set up the pissy foodie
situation since old tarts comes out to
me wants the pressure it's got him up
against the wall
oh you missed on the board as well but
here we go
having no leader at all Shem chin so
let's not borrow butter baby let's go
yeah definitely could use it for its Han
a damage wasn't one of the nicest things
about servantes despite his instances
disease of the damage out push that's
what keeps him in the game um in a lot
of moments is the fact that I'm sorry oh
my goodness stunning him for days a
Siringo like that home in okay as well
as pretty good bet you know I hear that
in saying oh my god no I love as well
and I love this weep o hit that just
happen right okay spray the soldiers get
away from me stop having me at the ball
I don't like that yeah definitely a
really strong option right there
she had a lot of but like very scarce
right now you couldn't get a good amount
of damage then he's got him at the lead
right there sold charts comes out from
new Gotham
situation here oh yeah you got the GI
anyway if you're gonna be able to do it
from this area the IDE alright oh my
goodness
beautiful from chef Chetan what
recognition diamond Wow just to get the
alighting just to get that ring out such
an impeccable job there we go but don't
right now we got to be careful chin chin
guard gage is slashing a lot of
potentially put lugod especially if he's
able to roll away from this ledge like a
good chance you gonna get the ring out
after dark break this I think that's why
probably why you're seeing the full
charge here right yeah a little bit more
than usual and it's working out for him
pretty well
okay trying to get the freaking tax on
the club frames he's here the wallet
yeah what are you gonna do break the
unbreakable Oh many shots close the card
breakers a chance nice walk on the low
he's gonna get sick maybe is not gonna
head comes out can't believe his guard
see flashing rent for as long as it did
it seems like it seems like Shanshan had
him walking for just long enough that
his own gardener would come back
gradually but no 6bb ended up hitting
the guard break got the CEO fit and
finishing it off and I mean damn was
that a closed set her match no once we
saw that lost what happened oh this is
it this is it and then bang just a
sliver of health in a dream Lou God
brought that back that's all anyone
needs at this point symmetry you just
gotta you just you know just keep your
health above zero right
oh here we go heading into our next
match if it were me I simply would have
blocked all the mix-ups end up changing
the stage there's no ring out possible
energy I represented right so we're
talking about how much mileage I was
getting in the last three games neither
super super good gonna get the eight-six
come right here and although we think
the GI right there is gonna give it a
spear no I did you know what I was just
thinking about it okay he definitely
definitely belongs it in the again
absolutely yeah hit me Cassandra for
sure
yo right Cassandra would I would for
sure be the best NBA Jam right there and
you God is currently on set and one of
the funniest things about Blues on
offense and she's always talking about
you a little bit over there
[Music]
conditioning is so important especially
in small set your gets higher level
talent dang just like that can be the
muscle to connect both another so much
meter to work but we'll pension let er
rip so here we go bull charging on them
gonna knock him down right there but oh
my god what a hit right into the sea II
lugod play me a symphony blue god my
love just like that clap it up clap
absolutely done as blue God moves on
here and loser bracket
unfortunately unlimited extension but
please give it up there for Shan Shan
Xue Shan Shan - David friends on Twitter
employ like y'all even when he when when
it's CEO is seeing the joy that spread
across his face right it's just every
time he plays this game it just means
the world to him so whenever he takes a
W it's like you can't help but feel the
joy in your heart - because of how hard
he